vor allem zum Anfang das letzte Video
vor dem Sommer haha gar nicht
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres herzhaftes
Rezept bei mir im Video und dieses Video
heute ist das letzte Video vor unserer
Sommerpause aber da komme ich später
noch dazu ich möchte heute leckere
rahmfladen machen bei uns heute das
Wetter so ein bisschen tatsächlich
herbstlich obwohl wir mitten im Sommer
sind oder Sommerpause kommt aber ich
habe mir gedacht heute haben wir ein
bisschen Lust auf was brotiges und so
ein bisschen was herzhaftes würziges und
diese mittelalterlichen raumfladen könnt
ihr gerne aus einem richtig leckeren
roggenteig herstellen und ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach zwei Versionen also einmal
könnt ihr die Mischung selbst machen ich
schreibe euch das Rezept gerne in den
Blog und schreibe euch alle Zutaten
genau hin oder ihr nehmt dann einfach
meine Brotbackmischung das ist nämlich
so ein roggenteig-form Mischung und da
sind einfach ganz viele tolle Gewürze
mit dabei Haferflocken Leinsamen
deswegen habe ich auch hier quasi für
euch mal die Zutaten dass ihr sehen
könnt in abgespeckter Version was hier
drin ist ich habe nämlich Roggenmehl
Roggenvollkornmehl E-Mail Haferflocken
Leinsamen sonnenblumenkerne sind auch
noch drin etwas Salz Majoran und Pfeffer
ist es natürlich nicht alles was da drin
ist aber das Rezept so wie ich es in
Block schreibe ist ungefähr so ein
bisschen abgespeckt man braucht halt
wirklich verschiedene Mehl um das dann
so ein bisschen geschmacklich gut
hinzubekommen aber ich verwende jetzt
hier heute meine Backmischung das ist
Brot Nummer 6 dafür brauche ich 480
Gramm Wasser einen halben Würfel Hefe
und es steht zwar nicht auf der Packung
drauf aber ich brauche noch ein bisschen
Olivenöl das würde ich nämlich bei dem
Hefeteig auch mit dazu geben der fliegt
nur Pflege die macht auch gleich
Sommerpause naja ich stelle die Zutaten
kurz weg und dann verrühren wir den
Hefeteig bzw verkneten
dann gebt ihr die Hefe mit dem Wasser in
eure Rührschüssel was ich noch vergessen
habe zu erwähnen bei dem Teig den jetzt
selber anmischen würdet muss auf jeden
Fall noch Roggen Sauerteig mit rein es
gibt getrocknet im Supermarkt in der
Backabteilung das ist hier quasi auch
schon mit drin
nicht kurz gucken die Kettmasche ja die
löst sich nämlich wenn man das hier so
wegschneidet da muss man die Tüte nicht
zerschneiden
und dann einfach auch die mehlmischung
dazugeben Olivenöl rein und etwa 10
Minuten lang kneten
ich finde das sieht man auch richtig
schön so die einzelnen Bestandteile die
da drin sind sie Leinsamen zum Beispiel
die Sonnenblumenkerne und unsere sechs
Brotmischungen die wir haben die werden
ja auch in so einer süßen kleinen Mühle
hergestellt alle für uns extra nach
unserer Rezeptur und jetzt sind wir
gerade am tüfteln auf wenn ich noch zwei
drei andere Sorten machen aber alles
schön aus dem Odenwald
das finde ich richtig schön weil dort
vor allem auch Mitarbeiter eingestellt
wurden die quasi für uns die
Brotmischung und herstellen und von
denen ich dann immer mal wieder
großbotschaften bekomme und das immer
schön dass man da sieht Werder so
arbeitet und das ist echt schön
[Musik]
so sieht der Teig jetzt wunderbar aus
der ist jetzt noch ein bisschen klebrig
wir sehen könnt
ist aber okay so denn der darf jetzt
erstmal aufgehen und das Mehl quillt
dann auch noch ein bisschen und er wird
dann eben einfach ein bisschen weniger
klebrig alles gut soweit das decke ich
jetzt hier kurz ab und kann in der
Zwischenzeit aber auch schon mal die
weiteren Zutaten vorbereiten nämlich die
rahmasse da mache ich noch Pesto dazu
aus Schnittlauch und die weiteren
Zutaten die so als Belag drauf kommen
ich lass mein Handy kurz was
[Musik]
für den rahmenbelag nehme ich 400 Gramm
Rahm da habe ich jetzt einfach etwas
Schmand Salz und Pfeffer und Knoblauch
und als Belag habe ich hier ein paar
Champignons getrocknete Tomaten die sind
Öl eingelegt etwas scharfskäse und wer
möchte kann auch gern Sucuk ergänzen
also eine Knoblauchwurst dann die
Knoblauchzehe in den Rahmen reindrücken
und wenn ihr die Knoblauchpresse benutzt
dann müsst ihr die Knoblauchzehe auch
nicht schälen
dann riechen die Finger nicht denn ihr
könnt dann hier ganz einfach sehen hier
ist jetzt noch die Knoblauch Schale
Schale oder Haut Schale hacken
damit Salz und Pfeffer abschmecken und
kurz verrühren
das
okay und dann zur Seite und dann nehme
ich jetzt hier die Champignons die
werden fein gehackt ja in feine Scheiben
die Tomaten und Sucuk in Würfel ich muss
sagen für meine Version nehme ich kein
Sucuk ich nehme einfach die getrockneten
Tomaten weil ich finde das getrocknet
Tomaten immer so schön würzig schmecken
und einfach einen guten Biss haben und
für mich tatsächlich oft auch als
Fleischersatz dienen und Schafskäse weil
er schön würzig ist aber für ein Murat
packen wir vielleicht doch noch ein
bisschen drauf
mal gucken vielleicht auch nicht
[Musik]
dann nehme ich jetzt hier den Schafskäse
das ist der bio-schafskäse von Gazi und
ihr könnt euch vielleicht noch daran
erinnern es läuft aktuell noch ein
Gewinnspiel und zwar könnt ihr wenn ihr
den Grill und pfannenkäse kauft nämlich
einen von zehn big green x gewinnen also
einen großen Grill mit Ausstattung und
da habt ihr hier einfach auf der
Verpackungs Rückseite einen QR-Code
könnt da die Infos auch nachlesen und im
Innern der Verpackung ist ein Code den
ihr eingebt und dann eben mit in den
Loosdorf kommt und das tolle daran ist
dass quasi jeden Monat gewonnen wird das
geht bis zum 31.08 und man kann halt
auch immer wieder teilnehmen das heißt
wenn ihr einmal mitgemacht habt heißt es
nicht ihr habt nur einmal die Chance
sondern ihr habt eben mehrfach die
Chance das ist ganz schön deswegen da
noch eine kurze Erinnerung an euch mit
dem Grillen pfannkäse hatte ich übrigens
auch ein Rezept gemacht das war mein
Stromboli Rezept also diese Art gefüllte
Pizza plus Grill und pfannenkäse falls
ihr euch erinnert draußen schön auf der
Terrasse erinnert euch ans Video falls
ihr es noch nicht nachgemacht habt
probiert es gerne mal aus strompoli ist
nämlich auch richtig lecker aber heute
passt Schafskäse zu meinem Rezept heute
gibt es Chance Käse so den Schafskäse
einfach ein bisschen zerkrümeln und dann
die Zutaten kurz beiseite stellen
so
dann habe ich jetzt den Ofen schon mal
vorgeheizt auf pizzastufe 220 Grad falls
ihr keine pizzastufe habt einfach ober
Unterhitze
jetzt nehme ich hier den Teig raus
und portioniere 12 Teile daraus
mag mir die Anna vielleicht den Torten
einteilen
wenn du lieb trägst
würdest du mir bitte den Torten
Einteiler geben damit ich 12 gleichmäßig
große schöne Stückchen
rauszubereiten kann
[Musik]
und dann zu kleinen Kugeln formen
ja ja ein Moment die Frau kann nicht
alles auf einmal
und dann rollt ihr die dünn aus nicht
ganz so dünn denn die Sonne richtig
fluffig werden also wenn ihr wollt dass
es so ähnlich wie ein Flammkuchen wird
dann schön dünn ausrollen und knusprig
ausbacken wenn ihr wollt dass es so ein
bisschen
brötchenbrötchen Brötchen ähnlicher ist
dann einfach ein bisschen dicker
ausrollen und dann werden sie mit dem
Rahmen bestrichen und mit dem Belag
eurer Wahl belegt und gebacken und in
der Zwischenzeit wenn das hier gleich
gebacken wird kann ich schon mal mein
Pesto zubereiten denn da passt ein
[Musik]
könnt ihr hier jetzt zum Beispiel den
Eisportionierer nehmen den mittelgroßen
und dann habt ihr immer die richtige
Menge auf jedem Stückchen
[Musik]
dann könnt ihr hier den Rahmen so ein
bisschen verteilen aber nicht ganz bis
zum Rand damit es nicht runter läuft
sondern damit da ein schöner krustiger
Rand entsteht
ich freue mich da echt schon seit Tagen
drauf dass ich das hier heute mache
habe heute einfach auch spontan den Dreh
umgeschmissen weil ich gesagt habe ich
habe heute Lust auf mittelalterliche
rahmfladen
[Musik]
Sucuk hat jetzt leider doch nicht drauf
gepasst für Murat
schade ich stelle dir kurz beiseite lass
dir noch mal etwa 10 15 Minuten aufgehen
und dann werden Sie direkt im heißen
Ofen bei pizzastufe gebacken die Zeit
kann ich aber auch gleich nutzen um ein
Pesto herzustellen
hier zwei pizzastufe schön weit unten
backen damit der Boden kross wird und
der Belag nichts doppelt ist
für das Pesto verwende ich Schnittlauch
etwas Olivenöl weißen Balsamico-Essig
Cashewkerne Parmesan Knoblauch Salz und
Pfeffer und die Frühlingszwiebeln nehme
ich später noch zum Bestreuen einfach so
[Gelächter]
gut also hier Pesto
schnittlauchpesto zuerst nehme ich jetzt
den Parmesan der wird hier in der
Maschine gerieben deswegen habe ich da
so eine reibescheibe drauf
[Gelächter]
okay ich kann wieder
Gespräche aus dem Schlafzimmer
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
dann reibe ich jetzt zuerst ein Parmesan
entferne dann die Reibe
[Musik]
dann kommt da die Knoblauchzehe dazu die
wird natürlich gestellt
und anscheinend ziemlich zerdrückt
[Musik]
und den Schnitzel auch
jetzt gebe ich einfach alle Zutaten rein
auch den Balsamico
und Salz und Pfeffer mache ich zum
Schluss und das Öl gieße ich auch
langsam dazu
jetzt nur noch mit Salz und Pfeffer
würzen und dann die Frühlingszwiebeln
fein hacken und dann kann ich nur noch
drauf warten bis die rahmfladen fertig
sind
fertig und jetzt könnt ihr diese
rahmfladen mit dem Pesto einfach
genießen ich habe übrigens eine gute und
eine schlechte Nachricht
die
[Musik]
okay ich habe nur eine gute Nachricht
okay die schlechte Nachricht ist meine
Information von vorhin vom Beginn des
Videos ist falsch es ist nicht das
letzte Video vor der Sommerpause denn
die gute Nachricht ist am Sonntag kommt
noch eine einschulungstorte
ja das ist die gute Nachricht siehst Du
bei uns gibt es nur gute Nachrichten
keine schlechten Nachrichten und die
gute Nachricht ist auch ich genieße den
rahmfladen jetzt alleine aber da ich
nicht gern vor der Kamera esse werde ich
das natürlich auch nicht vor der Kamera
Anbeißen dafür ist der rahmenfladen
nämlich zu dick
und ich zeige ihn euch so oh lecker
guckt euch das mal an wie Cross der
Boden ist und wie luftig locker das hier
irgendwas
richtig wird sich und lecker also
probiert das Rezept gerne mal aus nein
Anna ich werde jetzt nicht reinbeißen
wir werden gleich hinter der Kamera
probieren okay warte wer will noch
probieren bin noch immer probieren
ja
[Musik]
richtig gut
ist richtig lecker
ja probiert es gern mal aus und wie
gesagt für mich muss es gar kein Fleisch
sein perfekt mit dem Schafskäse denkt
und das Gewinnspiel was noch läuft bis
zum 31 August und dann sehen wir uns am
Sonntag wieder da packe ich wie gesagt
eine einschulungstorte und ich hoffe
euch hat dieses Rezept gefallen macht's
gut und bis zum nächsten Mal und ihr
dürft jetzt gerne über die Sommerpause
hinweg die jetzt bald kommt unter die
Videos schreiben welche herzhaften
Rezepte ihr euch gerne noch wünscht
jetzt gerade so für den Herbst und
Winter was da einfach noch so kommen
soll macht's gut und wie schmeckt
[Gelächter]
okay ich kann wieder